- [Voiceover] Hey grammarians, hey Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi David.
- [Voiceover] So we're gonna talk today
about the Oxford comma, which
is just another word for
another name for the serial
comma which is normally when you
have a list of things, you punctuate them
with a comma after each item.
So for example, in this sentence:
I'd like to thank my parents, comma,
Mahatma Gandhi, comma, and my pet hamster.
Or in this example: His favorite
artists are Elvis, comma,
a tiny Norwegian harpist,
comma, and Frida Kahlo.
Now this is a pretty big...
controversy in English is
where to put this comma.
Some style guides for example
the AP style guide recommends
that you don't include this last comma.
The style guide that Khan Academy uses,
the Chicago Manual of
Style, does recommend it.
Ultimately this is less about
grammar and more about style,
less about sense and more about taste.
'Cause you can make, I think,
a pretty convincing argument
against each one, like whether
to use the Oxford comma
or whether to not use the Oxford comma.
Paige, could you take me through
the possible ambiguity
in this first sentence?
- [Voiceover] Sure, so
this sentence without
the Oxford comma can kind
of look like you're saying
that you're parents are Mahatma Gandhi
and your pet hamster,
which is pretty crazy.
- [Voiceover] Right, and
the second one is a sort
of sentence that could be used
to make the argument
against the Oxford comma.
So his favorite artists are Elvis,
a tiny Norwegian harpist, and Frida Kahlo,
and it could be argued that
you're saying that Elvis,
the rock-n-roll progenitor, hip-swivel guy
was a tiny Norwegian
harpist, which is not true.
Both of these things are kind of examples
of assumed apposition that we're using.
We're using Mahatma
Gandhi and my pet hamster
to explain or clarify parents.
Or that we're using a
tiny Norwegian harpist
to explain or clarify Elvis.
And this is not the case.
I think you have to choose which kind
of confusion is more
important for you to avoid.
Frankly, the way to fix
these sentences is to put
the uncertain thing
elsewhere in the sentence.
So probably last, like I'd like to think.
Mahatma Gandhi, my pet
hamster and my parents.
And there's no confusion no matter
where you put the comma there.
Or his favorite artists
are Elvis, Frida Kahlo,
and a tiny Norwegian harpist.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, that does a good job
of avoiding that confusion.
- [Voiceover] A good craftsman
never blames their tools.
That's all I gotta say about that.
So Paige and I are here to report.
We're not here to make law.
We're trying to tell
you about the language
as it is and the way people use it.
Well we do at Khan Academy
is we use the Oxford comma,
so parents, comma, Mahatma Gandhi, comma,
and my pet hamster, or Elvis, comma,
a tiny Norwegian harpist,
comma, and Frida Kahlo.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] You have to find
a style guide and stick with it.
And sometimes that depends
on if you're writing
for a newspaper that uses
a particular style guide,
or if your English teacher
has a particular style guide
that they want you to abide by,
that's what you should follow.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
Different people will
tell you different things.
- [Voiceover] The key is to be consistent.
That's the Oxford comma.
That's the debate over it.
And it's really all about a false sense
of these being appositives.
So keep a wary eye out.
That's the Oxford comma.
You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.